Đôi ngoài chính thức thì đối với tốt là mọi mẹ thì phải ngoài là
Vừa làm buồn hợp, rồi hợp, rồi điều chỉ phải làm tiếp
Chắc có lúc nào để mời đi hợp ngoài nhau, đi đâu đôi ngoài ý đâu
Lại bạc đau vào bạc đồng ngoài tốt đạm thì tôi sẽ có đồng nghiệp
Ở, lắm tôi hợp đối hợp có thể hợp
Thấy百 xuống thuy, có thể hợp chấp sạm đối, thì có thể bị tá hợp
Hợp khó chấp, tôi dở vì ở đây hợp đạm
Bây giờ tên bán kiay không thì thì có cuộc gọi một anh tập trên
Bây giờ tâm, thì anh ấy anh ấy anh ấy xuổi của tôi
Nó, và anh có một câu là, đây mình còn phải xuổi cho cô đến này
Đó, phía gì, tôi phải ởm xanh xa, không phải ởm gì cả
tối chikuy toi
tối chikuy
tối lời
đoàn
tối nhớ là tối được sau là là việt với chủ tịch của
iOS XI là 3 chị thập động của Tét
tối xí xa mẹ ạ ạ ạ ạ ạ ạ ạ ạ ạ ạ ạ
tối được phần phần có người đi thập tung
thì phải sận đi viem là mặt hồ rời
đi tạm khu ba đình
thì trong quả tin thạch tông thì tốt cũng nói chưa được dại thích tui dời thiệu.
Ok, thì thôi khả chị em, các bạn cứ tổng,
là toàn nông rất đi đánh mì thôi, đúng không?
In my gravy có biết là ông phà mạnh đông, ông là ai không?
Ông là Mandarin, ông là quan lại, là điên quan lại,
nó tài sao dài điên quan lại,
nó đi chủ đông đi,
nó tâm dắt mạng, nó tình lợt tạo cách mạng,
nó có chói chói, nó điên,
có miếng là ai, cái khói dưới đoạn của báo dưới.
Và nó nó nói cho nên tên này,
tệ kia không hiểu cháng là,
là đi tưởng, yếu nướng, yếu, yếu,
cái báng nó to hỗ tưởng,
thì thành phân nó có hiểu là gì,
gương môi khách cuộc đe,
có chá là mật nướng vô,
là mật gì mật gì, là khiếm, giật mật ra,
là đoạn